what's up guys bang Bang there has been
a massive couple of weeks in the Bitcoin
industry first we have to start with a
pretty cool new Milestone now officially
one million Wallets on the Bitcoin
Network have at least one full Bitcoin
that's right there are one million full
bitcoiners now represented on the
Bitcoin Network and that means that
there are at least one million people
around the world with those wallets who
are just dollar cost averaging and
getting to a full Bitcoin that's pretty
cool to see now on top of that we have
the big news which is Blackrock coming
out of nowhere and filing for their ETF
application this would be very similar
to a Bitcoin spot ETF it's in a trust
structure forget the details it
basically would give people the ability
to have a publicly traded fund with
exposure to bitcoin with daily creation
and Redemption functionality now the SEC
has said hold on wait a second you guys
need to give us a little bit more
details specifically around this
surveillance sharing agreements and what
exact exchange you're going to be
partnering with but I do believe that
BlackRock which has 575 wins out of 576
attempts is going to get this ETF
eventually approved now we saw a bunch
of fast followers almost immediately
after that first application we saw
Fidelity we've seen Valkyrie and many
others all come forward and say we want
the Bitcoin spot ETF type product as
well and so now the SEC is going to have
to wait and see are they going to
approve these or are they not the big
dogs are banging at the door and they
want into the game and now related to
bitcoin one of my important investors
was on one of the television shows last
few days and he spoke about Bitcoin in
two of you know one monetary policy two
and three covet
um the hits on blackrock's on our
website was three thousand on covet 3
000 hits on a monetary policy and six
hundred thousand hits on bitcoin so what
that tells you is Bitcoin has is has
caught the attention and the imagination
of many people many people are
fascinated about it many people are
excited about it but it's still untested
it's still a pretty uh small Market
relative to other markets it really it
can be you know we see these big giant
movements every day it's a thin market
and so can it evolve into a global
market possibly certainly by evidence of
the imagination of so many who want to
learn about it are interested about it
to me is a very telling sign now once
one of these funds gets approved my
guess is that we're going to see a
billion dollars flow into these funds
within a short couple of days if we go
back and we look I think it took about
two days for the Futures based Bitcoin
ETF to get to a billion dollars in
assets a spot Bitcoin exposure would
probably do it even faster but that's
not all that the big dogs are doing in
the Bitcoin and crypto industry there's
a brand new crypto exchange that just
launched it's backed by Fidelity Schwab
and Citadel and so whenever you see
these big financial institutions
starting to get involved in the Bitcoin
and cryptocurrency industry first you
have to remember they didn't just make
these decisions overnight they probably
made these decisions months ago they
went through legal and compliance review
they had to build out the products they
had to put together the paperwork they
had to get all the approvals internally
and then and only then can they go ahead
and launch this stuff and so as the
saying goes bear markets are for
Builders and it looks like that's what
wall Street's been doing they've been
quietly building well the price Drew
down and people left Wall Street is here
they're pounding on the door and they
want in the game the big guys aren't the
only one who see the value in Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies either Jerome
Powell the FED chairman was recently
asked during a hearing whether he
thought that Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies had staying power and
he begrudgingly appeared to admit yes he
does believe that there are staying
power for these assets crypto and
digital Assets in the US has got a you
know market cap of around 1.1 trillion
dollars right now it's been there for a
bit do you acknowledge that this asset
class has staying power in the U.S
economy
it appears to have some staying power of
course that one 2.1 trillion was what
was that a year ago a lot higher yeah
yeah it's had some volatility in large
measure due to the lack of legal Clarity
and so hopefully this committee will
will help that quite a lot here uh this
summer uh with with at least two bills
one on stable coins and one on market
structure and it'll be clear not just
for congress but for Regulators
including chairman Gensler uh and and
obviously Market participants whether
they're um you know forming the ideas or
investing in the ideas or participating
in the activities now that's not
surprising the overall industry market
cap is over a trillion dollars Bitcoin
itself is over a 500 billion dollar
market cap and so the market has spoken
they believe these assets have value
they are allocating hundreds of billions
if not trillion plus dollars to the
industry and it's very unlikely that
you're going to see it go away
now there is a question of how big will
it get how long will it take but staying
power is not one of the things that
anyone is really questioning anymore
even the FED chairman is now openly
saying it Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
have staying power and they're likely to
be around for a long time speaking of
Bitcoin and that half a trillion dollar
market cap bitcoin's dominance of the
crypto Market is now over 50 percent
it's the first time that's happened
since April of 2021. Bitcoin has been
the king and Bitcoin Remains the king of
the industry I don't think that'll
change anytime soon Bitcoin having more
than 50 market share tells you that the
market has deemed it the most valuable
but also has the highest probability of
success moving forward there's a lot of
people with opinions there's a lot of
tribalism in the industry but I prefer
just to look at what the market is
telling you and bitcoin's dominance at
over 50 percent is one of those signals
that when you hear it you have to pay
attention one person and one company
that's been paying attention and has
been laser focused is Michael Saylor and
microstrategy they recently announced
that microstrategy bought another 12
333 Bitcoin that's right micro strategy
a single publicly traded company now
owns more than 152 333 Bitcoin they
spend about 4.5 billion dollars to buy
it and they obviously are very bullish
and planned to hold for the long term it
is not uncommon for public companies to
do things in terms of managing their
treasury but it is very uncommon for a
company to put Bitcoin on their balance
sheet and for someone to be so laser
focused that regardless of whether the
price is up or down they just continue
to dollar cost average and accumulate
Bitcoin
microstrategy now owns more than half a
percent of all Bitcoin that will ever be
in circulation that 152 333 Bitcoin is a
massive position so we're going to see
whether it's going to work out for them
or not
now what is interesting is they are now
profitable on that position Bitcoin
recently traded over thirty one thousand
dollars meaning that Bitcoin is up 86
percent to start the year bitcoin's
year-to-date return of 86 percent is
mind-blowing because if you look at the
headlines if you look at the mainstream
media no one's paying attention people
seem to just want to talk about the fact
that Bitcoin is down so significantly
from its all-time high of 69 thousand
dollars back in November of 2021
86 percent to start the year is a big
number and companies like microstrategy
that now own 152 333 Bitcoin should tell
you something and then the market
dominance of over 50 percent and then
Wall Street banging on the door and over
a million wallet addresses having at
least one full Bitcoin on the Bitcoin
Network
all these data points seem to be bullish
so it's shocking to me that so many
people are negative so many people seem
to be leaving and so many people seem to
be disinterested but that's how bear
markets work pay attention to the data
the market is screaming all sorts of
signals it's up to you to make sure that
you're listening and then you've got to
decide for yourself you got to do your
own research you got to figure out what
should you do for yourself and your
portfolio